[تصفيق]
ين وراين وتوفيقه يوسف عبد القادر يوسف
رئيس لجنه المسجد احنا بحمد الله في
الحاره هذه تعبنا تعب شديد وبدوا
ابنائنا من المعاناه وبحمد الله كانوا
واقفين وقفه كبيره جدا والله سبحانه
وتعالى من علينا وسمعنا واستا سرنا ان نقف
في هذه المكان صامتين ما خرجنا ابدا حتى
منى الله سبحانه وتعالى علينا بهذا هذا
الرجل نحن ما كنا الواحد والله يس يصل
المسجد ويرجع من المسجد كنا امات مننا عدد
كبير جدا في هذه الحاله وبحمد الله
وتوفيقه والله ما سجدنا الا ودعونا فنحن
بحمد الله وتوفيقه تفقد اليتيم تفقد
الضعيف نظم صفوف ابنائنا الله اك الله اك
نظم
صفوفه تفقد حالنا في هذا
هذا المكان ما كان فيه والله ولا واحد نظف
هذه المناطق وحده واحده وقف على موتانا
طلبنا منه ان يقومنا في هذا المسجد وكذلك
قواتنا
المسلحه الل ياسر والان اللوا اخونا اللوا
حاتم الله اكبر والكوكب واخواننا الضباط
الضباط الموجودين كلهم واخواننا ناس محمد
سليمان ديول كانوا شبكوا
مع الاتجاهات كلها فنحنا والله جينا
نحييكم على هذا
الصمود المواطنين الصمد ونحنا عارفينهم
عانوا في المويه عانوا في الكهرباء واكبر
من ذلك عانوا من القصر ودانات اخوانكم دول
ما مقصرين الناس دول كلهم الان كلهم قوات
مسلحه جهاز مخابرات شرطه مستنفر
مواطنين الان كلهم بيقلوا في صف واحد ضد
هذه المليشيا
المتمرده ال قلبت حياه الناس
معاناه لكن الشعب
السوداني وكل قطاعاته الان بيلغي دروس
بالرغم من
هذه المعارك الشرسه الشعب السوداني صامت
وراكز والمشايخ دول كلهم قاعدين وفي
مساجدهم وفي خلاويه وكلهم يعفوا الشعب
السودان احنا يا جماعه
الان المرحله مرحله المقاومه
الشعبيه المقاومه الشعبيه الان انتظمت كل
السودان ننا الان في لنه عليا ان شاء الله
تترتب المقاومه الشعبيه هتستقبل قادر على
حمله السلاح لانه يا جماعه الناس شافوا
العدوان حصل كيف وعارفين في التسعه شهور
دي الاستهداف بقى للمواطن هم لانهم جبنا
ما قدروا يواجهوا قواتنا المسلحه الدعام
ما بقدر جم الله اكبر الان حربهم ب ضد
المواطن لكن المواطن الان في المقاومه
الشعبيه ان شاء الله سند وحاجز دون تحقيق
احلامهما اطماعهم فنحنا يا جماعه جنا
نحييكم ونقف معاكم وجدنا من هؤلاء الشباب
والناس كله ثبات وكله جراه وكله اقدام دلي
و احنا مشينا هاجمنا معاليك هنا الشباب
دول كلهم فز جوران والله
طلب مدرس لا اله الا الله ان شاء الله
يكون هذا النموذج في كل السودان اك باذن
الله والنصر للسودان ونصر الم الله اكبر
اكبر وه من كلمه يا سيحق بكل
الشهداء العبل منا ومنكم جميع يا رب
العالمين وصل اللهم سلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله وحس تسليمه وجزاكم الله خير
وبارك الله فيكم يار وجزكم الله خير جزاكم
الله خير يا الله اكب الله
اكبر
شديدفي منك كف
شديد